hello everyone thank you for being here
to buy data Seattle 2000 3 23 and I'm
very happy for all you thank you
[Applause]
thank you all for supporting our open
source community and amelo is Elias and
I'm very happy to be here to give you
the opening statements
and so for everybody to know this is our
password for the Wi-Fi and please take
take a photo
and I would like to thank you all to all
our sponsors that make everything in
this conference possible and please help
me to to say thank you to our sponsors
with a very strong claps
[Applause]
thank you so much
and we are by data Seattle we are a
Meetup that started in 2017 and is made
by by all volunteers and we have diverse
backgrounds and we are presenting data
science related topics
and please join us to meetup.com
and by data is a worldwide meetup group
that is
is
um provided by Dom Focus for for us to
have an an open source space where we
can
um present our latest topics in data
science and please you can find any
um
as you can see in the map any Meetup
near to your country or state
and for now please help me to bring our
executive director Leah silin
to the stage
[Applause]
thank you
good morning it's great to see everyone
here and um it is super exciting to be
back for another Pi data in the Seattle
area it has been been way too long so a
huge thank you to Microsoft again for
support and for the incredible credible
venue it's um such a pleasure to be back
here and we're grateful also for we will
give a shout out to Microsoft also for
the support for the New York City venue
as well very grateful for that so
um thank you thank you for coming it's
the community
the whole num focused community and open
source scientific Community is huge and
it seems to be growing every day and
then focus is here to support the
projects that you are using and that the
community is working on but also that so
much of the so many in the community are
contributing to both code and non-code
contributions it's great to see also
growth in the contributor base and we
greatly encourage everyone who isn't
contributing to a non-focused open
source project or another project
to go to the contributor guidelines
check those out see if there's a way for
you to get involved we make sure all the
focused projects have a real easy point
of entry so think about contributing in
that way or volunteering for numb Focus
we're here to support the projects and
also you the user community and we would
love to have your participation and
invent whether it's with events or
meetups or some of our volunteer
community committees that we have
growing right now so be sure you check
those out on our website we have lots of
opportunities for you to get involved
and as mem Focus continues to grow we're
we're really taking a year to carefully
look at how we can scale there's a lot
of projects that want to be under the
num Focus umbrella that need these
project services so they can continue on
their growth cycle and we can ensure
their sustainability so we are we're
really taking a look back also at where
we've come over the last now we're in
our 11th year and where we're going and
exactly how we can get there most
efficiently so that we can serve these
projects and also serve the community in
the best way that we can so super
excited to be here thank you to you
thank you to all of our sponsors
your your impact is huge please know how
how much of a difference that makes we
count on it and it is it helps us to do
the work that we're we're here to do and
fulfill that mission and yes thank you
sponsors
and also want to thank everyone who's
presenting
um who give those who presented
tutorials yesterday and those who will
be speaking today
um everyone's here to come gain
knowledge exchange that knowledge which
with each other and
um we can do that without the incredible
content that we have that speakers are
delivering so thank you so much to you
and also all the volunteers couldn't be
a great another great Pi data event
without you so thanks so much
thank you so much Leah
so with that note please help me to
welcome the representative of Microsoft
Andres Mueller
[Applause]
good morning everybody so it's a new
thing for me to be representative of
Microsoft I've been involved in the
pyrita community probably for at least
10 years I'm a secular current developer
for over a decade and so it's a great
pleasure to welcome you all on the
Redmond campus on behalf of Microsoft so
I'm really excited that we can host the
conference again here together in person
and
um
so I'm really excited for her talks I
actually don't want to take away any
more time from uh the amazing keynote we
all have and I hope I can see you all
um during the coffee breaks
thank you so much thank you Microsoft
for hosting us
and we have a code of conduct please
um be excellent to each other and
please um we have
um these
um
a link in your information for for the
ticket for attending the conference and
we have many volunteers for this
um for today program we also have four
Keynotes 16 tutorials that was yesterday
and 42 talks between today and tomorrow
and please attend our two partners event
one is a diversity panel and that one I
would like to encourage everyone to
attend so you come became uh you can get
knowledge and how to become a better
Ally and you are going to hear very cool
stories from us and I really appreciate
non-focus personally and by data because
I'm a woman I'm come from Mexico and
English is my second language and I'm
here in front of you talking and I'm
very happy and honored to be here thank
you so much
and our meals are tomorrow every day
breakfast eight to nine lunch daily
and the the food is amazing in here I
really like it
and we have our social event today
please stay and networking with us
and we have three sponsors for our
social event and could you please help
me to thanks our sponsors for the social
it's going to be amazing we are going to
have drinks and appetizers
and these are
okay
um these these are all the people from
the by the Seattle conference com
committee and we are volunteers as I
said at the beginning and please help me
to thanks all all of us to that made
this conference possible and we spend
many many hours for you to have a great
time here and to bring you the best of
data science right now in the Pacific
Northwest thank you so much to all
different comedy
and also thank you so much to the
speakers volunteers contributors
and all to all our friends non-focus and
by data friends
and with this I would like to introduce
uh I'm so honored to introduce Dr
Katrina real she is the president of the
board of directors of non-focus thank
you
all right so first off I just want to
thank everybody for inviting me here
this is a really great honor to be back
here at the Microsoft Center here in
Seattle a fun fact this is actually the
first uh conference center in fact the
same room where I gave my very first
conference talk ever at a pi data event
back in 2015 actually so it's pretty
cool to be back here
um but I do want to talk a little bit
about my story and how I wound up kind
of getting where I'm at
um
as mentioned before this is actually
kind of an interesting story and it kind
of explains a little bit about what I'm
talking about here it's
I came to open source through scientific
Computing so my undergraduate degree is
in molecular biology I worked in a
population genetics lab and we were
doing an a huge amount of number
crunching back in Excel and sometimes
Mathematica and it was really really
painful just so you know it was not the
best experience my older brother at the
time was working at Nasa he was working
on the International Space Station
guidance system which was written all in
C and they were actually using python in
order to test the code which was pretty
cool he came to visit he really wanted
to see my lab and he kind of saw what I
was doing saw me suffering through some
of the number crunching I was doing and
he said that that maybe there was a
better way for me to do this and it
opened this entirely New Direction for
everything I did after that obviously
I'm not a biologist anymore and I moved
on and into it to an entirely different
direction
um the things that I really liked about
using python were basically the
accessibility it was freely available we
had open source tools that were of
quality that were available to all
scientists it was easy for me to teach
it and share it it was easy for me to
learn it it was easy for me to interact
with the community it was easy for me to
ask questions of other scientists in
order to understand what was going on
and why we were using it in the way that
we were
it it's an interesting idea because you
always hear this within this community
is that you come for the language you
stay for the community right we all are
a part of this community and we are all
part of this knowledge share that's
involved here
so I took a turn in my career I ended up
moving into artificial intelligence
which was something that I really
enjoyed I ended up going into graduate
school for computer science
and I got my first job uh I didn't did
that okay sorry
my first job at an artificial
intelligence startup that was founded by
the former Chief Financial Officer of
Texas Instruments actually and I got
really lucky I was an officer in the ACM
chapter on campus and they gave a
presentation talking about their brand
new startup and how they were working in
artificial intelligence and they were
using python at the time obviously no
one was using python I was a huge fan
already I went to talk to them and
that's how I scored my first software
development job and that's where I wound
up staying actually was in artificial
intelligence working in r d in
artificial intelligence especially with
these really seasoned r d people out of
Texas Instruments made me want to move
in that direction
so I stayed in artificial intelligence
and wound up actually going into a PhD
program in computer science
at this point I want to mention that
python was still not popular
I was the python geek in the department
that everyone made fun of that everyone
kind of you know was uh
yeah a lot of things thrown my way
actually for being a part of the
community but it was also around this
time that I became very involved in open
source as a lot of graduate students do
when they move into a research setting
and they are working on something
generally a lot of scientists they are
creating code in order to advance their
own own research but then they want to
share it with everybody else that they
we do have the spirit of community and
we do have scientific inquiry that we're
moving these things forward
um
but uh
so I started working in open source
while I was working on my PhD by the way
all of the software that I created for
my own research as a PhD student was
open sourced as well it was at the time
we didn't have anything like GitHub we
had various SVN super servers all over
the place or people would put you know a
a tar file up on their website or
something like that we did have
sourceforge which was a really good
resource for a lot of people to use but
it was a very different era in which
people were creating software and
sharing it with each other
I had this dream when I finished that I
wanted to stay in the open source area
so
when I finished my PhD I joke about this
that the dream was to get paid to do
open source and this turned out to be
way harder than actually getting my PhD
and so I had plenty of offers from
industry in every area that I could
possibly want to go but this was the
dream this is where I wanted to go I
thought of myself as a scientist even
though I was still in the computer
science area and I wanted to support
scientific Computing so a lot a lot of
people probably in this room I wound up
at n thought who at the time was housing
numpy and scipy
and so that's where I wound up so I'm
not going to go into all the places I
bounced around after that I worked in
government I've worked in industry I've
started data science teams at cloudflare
and at
um also with verbo as part of that team
I was part of Expedia most recently I
was hired as the head of the data team
over at streamlit and uh which was
acquired by snowflake recently I retired
actually so I am now an adjunct lecturer
at Georgetown University and I also just
do this so the dream of doing open
source full time
really came true because I sold out and
now I'm bringing my soul back right
so that's what at least
um I say that with love because I
actually met amazing people along the
way and I'm very very fortunate in my
career but this is this actually has
been my dream and it was by design that
eventually I knew I was going to be
leaving so that I could
um follow this dream of doing open
source full-time and teaching and that's
what I'm doing now as of last month by
the way
um so that's that's how that went
um I joined the num Focus board of
directors in 2018.
um I was really honored to be a asked to
join obviously the board of directors
they do searches out amongst the
community and find people who are active
and ask them to join so I came on as
Treasurer actually so I joke a lot about
um I talk a lot about money for numb
Focus which you're going to get to later
on in this talk but I joke around a lot
about you know the treasure is usually
the most boring job on a board until you
hit a pandemic and then it becomes a lot
more interesting so we'll talk about
that a little bit
um and then I became the president of
the board in 2021.
um since then I've been obviously just
around
um I I recently as of like I guess last
week took over the pie Vis project
actually so his first time a project
maintainer in a really long time I'm
really excited to get that back off the
ground so like I said it's kind of an
interesting story but I don't think that
it's an uncommon story for people in the
scientific community that you start off
doing your own research you find out
that there's this community of sharing
you get really really involved in it and
then we had all of these revolutions
that happened right that python took off
or scientific Computing took off other
languages came in to the scientific
Computing realm we have you know R
coming in we have Julia coming in we
have Stan coming in we have all of these
other things that are happening here and
you just move in another Direction it
also within this time became big
business
where people were able to make a living
in these areas and that scientific
Computing array Computing became the de
facto way that we approached data
science which has become this huge boom
just this huge bomb that's you know in
the middle of this community so I just
want to kind of mention this because
we're going to look back quite a bit I
think during this whole thing and I want
to talk about open science quite a bit
here because I actually do still
consider myself a scientist I know
that's really funny at this point but I
do still consider myself ultimately a
scientist the core mission of numb focus
is actually to support scientific
software and the scientific community
and we'll get into that a little bit
more as well but when you look at open
science I want to lay the groundwork
here so you can kind of understand how
this interplay between open source and
open science works because within open
science you have to have obviously open
code so that you have reproducibility
you have scalability you have multiple
eyes on it you're sharing knowledge
people are able to move forward with
research they were able to tap into a
community of people that are making
things better
open data is obviously a really
important thing and that's something
that we're getting into more and more if
you don't have data available it's going
to be really hard to do science and this
is something that I think that
especially within the government you're
seeing more and more data sets being
shared you know out of NASA out of the
Space Telescope out of tops out of a lot
of different programs that are out there
right now
obviously open papers this is a big one
that for a long time
scientific papers you know they're
behind a paywall it's really really hard
to get access to good scientific
research and
as part of this community I think that
we have shown ultimately that we can
publish notebooks we can publish papers
we can put things out into the open
arena so that we can work on science as
citizen scientists as opposed to being a
part of an academic institution or a
part of you know publishing within a
journal that may or may not have open
access
and then also open reviews so open
evaluation is a really big thing and so
this goes back to the idea of
reproducibility which is a big tenet of
numb Focus as well by the way
reproducibility in scientific thought is
obviously important we want to make sure
that when we are looking at something
that we can reproduce it that the
results are valid and so we want to also
do all of these things based on the
principles of inclusion fairness equity
and sharing right so the idea that
everyone is invited to the table that
this is a conversation that is not just
for some people it's for everyone who
chooses to be a part of it and that's
something that really appeals to me and
especially as somebody that you know
coming as a bench scientist where it was
almost impossible for me to do genetic
research without a thousand dollars
worth of chemicals and event hood and
you know ten thousand dollars for my PCR
machine and five thousand dollars for
this or my centrifuge and all these
other things like that suddenly all I
needed was a personal computer and an
internet connection and I was completely
hooked into a scientific community and I
could do pretty much anything that I
wanted to
my it was only Bound by my imagination
and the amount of time I was willing to
put into it and to me that was magic
and so but I also want to mention that
where we came from within the open
source Community
um these are the events that I wanted to
mention there are several events in the
Milestones of Open Source but I kind of
want to walk you through some of these
because they're the ones that shaped me
quite a bit in my own view of open
source of the influences I had at my own
uh own life the first thing that I
wanted to go back to though back in the
1950s and 60s a lot of computers were
very academic this was something that
you know software was shared as part of
your Hardware there was no such thing as
an operating system back then so it's a
very different Paradigm for people to
think about code was open by default
because it was a small community of
academics mostly that were all sharing
information with these brand new
machines that were out there
but as things progressed on and suddenly
the proliferation of computers happen
you have operating systems there were
actually court cases around the fact
that it was
Anti-Trust in order to bundle your
computers with software and so these
things became separate things it was the
first time that software started being
considered a commodity that it itself
had value because the cost of developing
software Rose
um relative to the cost of developing
hardware and you start seeing this sort
of split that's happening here you also
have operating systems coming into play
you have other code that's coming into
play
and then what happened as a result of
this 1974 is what the first time that
really it was be aware of the fact that
code is copyrightable so this is where
all of the licenses that we all love
talking about this is where it all
starts right back in 1974 where suddenly
code is copyrightable as if it were a
work as if it were authored by somebody
like a regular fiction book it's
something that is copyrightable
so that is still in play today obviously
that's why we have all these fun
licenses I do want to mention the 1976
letter that Bill Gates wrote The Open
Letter to hoppiness which a hobbyist
later became known as hackers I know
that we are on the Microsoft campus but
I do want to mention this because for me
this was very very influential because
it was the first time that somebody
stood up and said hey we're not okay
with people uh
sharing our code basically about sharing
things without a valid license and
that's where a lot of the conversation
started around whether or not you need
to have a license and what does it mean
to have software on your machine and who
is the person who owns it and what are
your rights when you have this the
software and it was definitely something
that was referred back to multiple times
especially in my childhood in my own
household of nerds and it was something
that definitely shaped a lot of things I
do want to mention as a result of this
by the way that Microsoft is a very
different place now than it was back
then right they have a very large open
source Community obviously and a lot of
their policies have changed I'm only
bringing this up basically because this
open letter was so influential I think
within the history and the Milestones of
Open Source the next thing I wanted to
talk about was 1983 the internet already
existed we've already we know this and
there are a lot of debate about what the
birth the birth date of the internet is
I'm choosing 1983 for a reason the
reason is because we moved to tcpip
when we moved to tcpip we suddenly had a
uniform protocol that was open that
everyone could conform to before that
the internet had a lot of
a proprietary interfaces that people
were using but what this did by having
an open standard by having something
that everyone could connect to and that
could be implemented suddenly you have
an open communication gate that anyone
can be a part of
once again
so this is 1983 so now we've got the the
substrate right we've got we've got the
means at which to be able to actually
communicate with each other in an open
way
then 1983 was also when the gnu project
started so stalman obviously was the
person who started this and you know not
getting into the whole
controversies around gnu and everything
like that but this is the when the idea
of copy left came up right people were
working on projects they wanted to have
these licenses and then wanted to be
able to keep it open so if you had a
good new license on your software it
could be reused but you had as a copy
left idea so it had to be attributed
back and it also had to stay open if you
were going to work on this and so this
led of course into the free software
Foundation obviously very very important
in everything involving open source and
shaping the way that we look at open
source
1989 I'm going to talk about the 386 BSD
development started and this is where
the BSD license came from
uh the reason I actually bring this up I
don't think that the 386 BSD development
was particularly
like groundbreaking but the BSD license
is because this is the first time that
you had a license
where suddenly software was completely
distributable so this one came out of
Berkeley right the Berkeley software
distribution
um and
this led to the Apache license and the
MIT license which even to this day
Apache three claws MIT license BSD
licenses these are the most popular
licenses we see especially in the num
Focus community and this allows free and
fair views where suddenly we don't have
this copy left restriction we can use
all of the software reuse it in any way
that we want to basically
and that is a revolution I think in the
way so the idea being that we want to
push adoption as opposed to attribution
and um and so a lot of projects
obviously move in this direction want to
also discuss 1991 is when the lytics
kernel so lightest Torvalds everyone's
obviously heard of this suddenly in the
open source world we had a kernel in our
operating systems that was fully open so
now we have the whole stack
we've got the internet we've got a
kernel for our operating system we've
got KDE we've got all the open uh you
know software that we need in order to
move forward
it was possible for around the first
time that you didn't have to buy any
software in order to be able to get
started and move forward if you had a
machine that was very possible if you're
willing to hunt and Peck and find
everything that you need to do and
obviously have a certain amount of Savvy
in order to be able to compile things
yourself and get things running on your
own but you were able to actually do
Computing without having to go to
proprietary software
and I mentioned this because one of the
tenets of Open Source I think sometimes
people forget is that we didn't want all
of the Power of this new Computing world
that we were a part of to be owned and
restricted by certain entities certain
corporations as being the ones who owned
all of the IP and all of the ideas for
this revolution in our world
so suddenly we want to be in this
position where especially within the
scientific Computing realm we want to
have tools that are freely available
that there is no barrier to entry that
people can use and be able to push
forward thought
and that was what we really wanted as
opposed to using the commoditization of
software and using that as a means to
kind of control the market and control
who has access
okay all right
I talked about I added 1993 in the
founding of red hat this is where we see
for the first time that you can that
open source is big business when Red Hat
was founded this was a huge new idea no
one had ever started a company based on
an open source project and they not only
succeeded but when it actually hit it
went public it was one of the largest
opening days of like any company ever up
to that point right so this is where it
suddenly okay I don't know what happened
there but uh okay
um but yeah we have um
uh it opens the door for all of the
others that came after this right so we
have
um too many to even to even name at this
point right
um so it opened the door for you know
everything from git lab to Docker to
um graffata all of these other companies
where we have open source software as
being the basis for our company so now
we've moved it back into a a world where
we have industry and science all working
together there are all of these
different things we have money that's
being poured into the community as well
as a result of this
all right so 1997 I added this one
because the Raymond uh
uh article the cathedral and the bazaar
was probably one of the most influential
things that I read back when I was in
college and so this was really shaped
the way that I looked at software and
the way that I thought about software
and if you haven't read it it's actually
you know it's part of Computer History
it's probably a good read even to this
day but the idea that you have these two
different ways of looking at software
development so you have the cathedral
idea where you have periodic releases of
software and in between it's really
opaque what happens in between that time
all the development happens kind of
offline often the group of people that
are developing it the only time that you
actually see it is back is when they do
a release
and so a lot of people still use this
obviously nothing wrong with it but the
other way of looking at it is the
bizarre idea and Linus tarvault was
definitely a big influence in this one
as well the idea that you have as many
eyes as possible on the software that
you're going to find the bugs you're
going to find the good ideas and you're
going to move forward in an open way
so this was software development in the
open and so obviously the bizarre um
idea has really really taken off
GitHub is obviously the
revision control of choice for most open
source projects and a lot of that that
is open right once you have it out there
anyone can read it anyone can comment on
it anyone can have an opinion about it
and so that puts us into that area so
having as many eyeballs on the on the
code the idea is that then we have more
of a conversation we're sharing
knowledge
and I also just want to add that one of
the things that really I took from this
paper it became a book later but uh when
you when you go through this every good
work of software starts by scratching a
developers itch and that goes way back
into the scientific software Community
right we have scientists developing
software because something is very very
painful to them so for example number
crunching in a population genetics lab
not particularly fun
scratching that itch
all right and then I added 1998 is when
the open source initiative happened this
came out of the open source Summit
it was originally the freeware Summit it
was renamed the open source Summit it
was hosted by Tim O'Reilly the the
publisher and there were a lot of people
at the table that you've probably all
heard of including um Guido van Rossum
who's the creator of the Python language
and that's where the actual term open
source was was coined there was a vote
open source one that was the term that
everyone used and there's a very
pragmatic approach to open source it's
not necessarily the same thing as you
know freeware or you know free software
but the open source Community is
generally where I am and this is where
we are sharing information we are using
OSI approved licenses we are sharing
software and we are able to
um
oh
anyway this gave us a common language is
what I'm getting at I guess is the way
to look at this is that now we have a
vocabulary we have a way to unify this
area I'm so sorry Everybody by the way I
didn't expect this to go to sleep
um but anyway these are the ones that I
chose
um anyone can pick other dates but this
is my view of the world and kind of the
things that really shape the way I
looked at software but then going back
to
um I'm very active in the python
Community is where I started going back
and looking at how all of these
different packages and all of these
different things that happened within
our community all built upon each other
we have all standing on the shoulders of
each other and I know that there will be
many people in this room are developers
on these projects or have been involved
in these projects and definitely
passionate users of these projects but
we see this over time you know all the
way from 1991 where python was one of
the first you know completely open
languages
numeric by the way if you're ever part
of the numbering numeric
the debates what a lot of older people
like me dinosaurs we we went through
that whole debate and then obviously in
2005 numpy was actually founded out of
out of all of this
um Travis you know he's one of our
keynote speakers he's the creator of
numpy so you could he's probably not
going to talk about that but I thought
it was a huge Revolution at the time
especially as somebody who was a user
um back then
and so IPython scipy matplotlib scython
scikit-learned and we had Andres up here
who was one of the core maintainers of
that one started as a Google summer of
code project right and uh we have pandas
psychic image number Jupiter desk
tensorflow there's so many projects I
could keep going on and on and on and on
but these are some of the really really
important ones that I think that you see
a lot of adoption around so I wanted to
really shout those out there's one thing
that I did not add into this one is that
in 2012 the formation of numb focus is
obviously super super important there
are multiple foundations out there you
know Apache Foundation Linux Foundation
you have all of these different entities
that are helping out but we'll get into
num Focus quite a bit and how we're a
little bit different because we are
supporting the scientific community
so from here I just want to mention that
these packages where we're all standing
on the shoulders of each other's they
are making a huge impact in this world
you see this in scientific thought and
in scientific discoveries all the time
the first photographs of the black hole
that we all saw the laser inferometer
gravitational wave Observatory
Observatory it's the first time that we
were able to see gravitational waves
right these were predicted by Albert
Einstein a hundred years ago it was the
first time that we were able to see
really really violent collisions in
space
using all of these tools that are out
there and earned a Nobel Prize rightly
so
we have over 188 000 project citations
in in scientific papers out there
um I think a lot of people I think that
number's low to tell you the truth
because I think a lot of people don't
realize that you can cite software
packages in your papers but um there is
actually a way to do that the style
guides now have that of how you can you
can reference papers but
um those are the ones that I saw in our
in our impact report
um supporting technical information
innovation
all of these projects are everywhere
we've seen them distributed in all kinds
of different things I won't even go
through all of them but we see it over
and over and over again that the you
know they're becoming ubiquitous in our
world
and then the Google collaborative
collaboratory and Netflix they're using
a lot of you know Jupiter notebooks a
lot of things moving forward in that
area I know that uh well I won't get
into the whole notebook thing because I
think I'm actually running out of time
but and another one I wanted to shout
out very uh self-servingly is the fight
for human on humid trafficking
um I was one of the co-in principal
investigators of the DARPA MX program so
we were using open source for the first
time that was being funded by DARPA to
release tools to fight human trafficking
in an open way as part of the DARPA open
catalog this was a new way of looking at
it the idea was that suddenly you've
reduced the barrier to entry for any law
enforcement agency to have access to
Quality software in order to fight a
common problem and it was also a means
by which the government was recognizing
that open source has a means of
distribution was a valid way to get
software into the hands of others
and so
um you know like I said I could talk
about this quite a bit actually that's
what I talked about when I was on the
stage for the very first time by the way
and I know that we have at least one
memix uh developer in here
um but anyway
um
and then also so we were mostly mining
the deep and dark web when we were
looking for Rigs of human traffickers
and a lot of new tools a lot of
innovation came out of this because we
were not bound by anything we could use
any of the open source projects but we
also were in the position that we could
collaborate with any of the open source
projects in order to build the tools
that were necessary in order to do the
things that we wanted to do on the
project so if there was a feature that
was necessary we could contribute it
back and suddenly we had a better
Library as a foundation for what we were
trying to do and I I just thought it was
a really great way to do research and I
would like to see more projects Run This
Way unfortunately the administration
that came in after that was not as
friendly to open source they shut down
the DARPA opaque catalog we had a lot of
trouble trying to find hopes for all of
the new things but um you know our
current Administration has a much more
open view of that they brought a lot of
things back as well as the open data
that's available through the X data
program is also made available again
all right so why do I believe in open
source
democratization of Technology obviously
as a person who
did not necessarily have a background in
computers I suddenly had access to all
of these different tools that I could
play around with that I could program
that I could modify that I could share
and I thought that was really really
cool I also do want to mention that as a
woman in technology I have to say that
having a supportive environment where I
could collaborate with others was
unbelievably necessary for me to be able
to move in this direction so being able
to be in a position where
technology should not be shut out from
50 percent of our population it's just
too much a part of our lives at this
point so if we are shutting people out
there are other ways and other roads for
people to get involved and I think that
this is a very valid one
um freedom to adapt and alter code as I
mentioned before tapping into the Brain
Trust we're all in this together we all
want to solve cool problems we all want
to do cool things but we also can share
ideas and get into that place where wow
that's a really great idea I'm either
going to beg bar or steal it that's cool
because I can do that in this kind of
environment education I recently just
finished teaching my first semester
after a really really long time of not
teaching last time I taught was actually
when I was at anaconda and I was doing
like corporate trainings which is not
the same thing but in education suddenly
we have all of these open tools that are
freely available to students so we're
able to get people on the ground working
with real code with some of the best
programmers in the world as the ones who
are guiding them and then also be able
to
um uh open that door like there you can
be on the very Cutting Edge of what's
happening in your field as opposed to
for example in biology where you may be
a little bit constrained by what's
available to you and who has access to
the laboratory equipment and to all of
the grant money and all of the different
jobs in that particular you know
biochemistry field or something like
that
um practical experience I will admit
that especially back when I started
doing open source you got to have a
pretty thick skin to contribute to an
open source project but like I said if
you are willing to put in the time and
to work with other people you have the
opportunity to work on a real project
with people who do know what they're
doing who are willing to teach you and
hopefully are open to the idea of
working with you in order to make you
better at what you're doing business
opportunities
I can't count the number of of startups
I've seen that are founded on open
source projects the ones that I always
laugh about I guess about four years ago
it's like every startup I heard about
was founded on scikit-learn it's like
basically like
you know
practically powering a whole portion of
our economy at this point right if the
projects were to fail that obviously
would be very detrimental in fact to our
economy
career opportunities I personally
recruit out of Open Source all the time
well I guess not anymore now that I'm
not anybody anymore but
um I love recruiting from open source
communities because they're you see what
people are capable of doing but they
also have that you know passion for the
mission of what you're doing
research and development research and
development costs go way down when
you're working in open source an open
scientific inquiry and sharing obviously
so this is where we finally get to numb
Focus so numb focus is huge and I am so
sorry that we recently just had another
round of Affiliated projects that were
added so I don't think my counts are
completely up to date on like how many
projects we have but
um a lot of these I'm sure you're all
aware of
um you know our first by the way um a
project to receive funding through num
Focus was IPython and so that's kind of
cool that's like what 10 years ago that
that nine years ago that they received
that was the first time that we were
able to pay open source developers
through a fiscal entity entirely devoted
to open source and open science
um this is a revolution I just got you
know I kind of sometimes want to make
sure that people understand like it was
the Wild West for real back you saw
projects succeed and fail and like I
mentioned before it was really really
hard to figure out a way to make a
living and build a career as an open
source developer you had a lot of
um like I said just things people would
disappear code would disappear there
were all kinds of different issues that
would happen the number of projects that
I more projects I worked on failed that
succeeded and that was the norm but by
having an entity that is independent and
scientifically oriented suddenly we have
a home where we can provide services to
help
these projects to be more successful
to be totally clear we do not dictate
any technical direction we are not the
people who you know uh you know do the
work we're you know most of the people
that are on the board are involved in
some sort of project and and things like
that but we're we are Community Driven
but we are not the ones who you all are
doing the work like the open source
projects are the ones that are out in
front they're the ones who make this
community we're here to support because
we believe in the mission of what what's
happening here and so
um going back to this idea the mission
of numb focus is to promote open
practices and research data and
scientific Computing by serving as a
fiscal sponsor for open source projects
and organizing Community Driven
educational programs so what does this
mean I want to break it down just a
little bit fiscal sponsor is a term of
art I just want to mention this this is
a legal term it does not mean that we
are the ones who pay for all of these
projects and all of these things we are
a non-profit organization that's able to
act as a fiscal entity for projects that
means that projects need money they
absolutely need money they need other
sources of funding in order to come in
but we can do Grant Administration we
handle you know tax reporting we do
making sure that things are in order on
the on the back office the whole idea is
to provide these services that make it
possible for the technology to move
forward and so this is what creates the
stability and like I said going back to
the idea that this something like this
being Community Driven is huge
it's it's not it's developers who came
up with this idea that they needed a a
non uh
needed an independent area to provide
this home right and it was definitely
something that I was very interested in
from the very beginning and wish that we
had had a lot sooner
um
so
I mentioned this a little bit I'm so
sorry I am running out of time so I'm
not going to go through all of our
services and everything but um
obviously we provide legal services
financial services operational Services
all these things that people don't want
to do I do want to mention licensing and
trademarking though because I think a
lot of people forget about this that
part of an open source project is
building a brand like if you have the
everyone wants their their software to
be used but if you have people who are
infringing upon the name of your project
how are you ever going to be able to
build that brand and be able to say like
this is the project that you're working
with it's quite possible without
trademarking and copywriting and
Licensing and all of these things like
that that you could have somebody just
start
a company called scikit-learn and they
they could just do that and suddenly
they are the people who would be known
as scikit-learned but protecting that
brand protecting the idea of what it is
and what this stands for I think is
really really important and so you know
sometimes people are like oh well you
know you're just training logos and
you're making sure that people aren't
misusing things it goes a little bit
more than a little bit deeper than that
because branding is really important if
you don't have users you don't have a
project
I mean you can continue to
um build anything you want out in the
open but most of us want others to use
what we're doing we want to be able to
get that adoption we want people to be
moving forward to conversation so I just
want to point that out we also you know
handle contracts agreements I mentioned
tax reporting technical infrastructure a
lot of the documentation websites are
hosted by us and we all behind
cloudflare and you know making sure that
things are up and running
um and then obviously conference and
event planning I think some people may
or may not be aware of the fact that
this is a numb focused event like you
all have here lanyards that say numb
Focus Pi data and numb focus is the same
people it's the same entity
um it's not anything different people
always ask me about the relationship
between those things the same people
that are working in the num Focus lot
they're the ones who are putting these
on these are non-focused employees right
here and so
um uh moving on from the I'm actually
going to move forward a little bit
faster but um the pi data conferences
are obviously really important obviously
you all find Value in being here
otherwise you wouldn't be here
but this is an opportunity for us to get
developer communities user communities
in the same room and have a conversation
because a lot of the technologies that
people are using on the user side are
not necessarily the same technologies
that are used in order to create the
libraries
and so understanding better what
people's needs are understanding better
you know what needs to happen on a
project who is using it who is your
audience what they have to say and then
also recruiting into your projects
um are very very important
um so once again thank you to everyone
for being here and then also for um you
know participating as you know
developers and speakers and all of the
other other wonderful things that are
happening I'm obviously very biased but
I love this community I just think it's
amazing what what how far we've come and
what we're able to do
as part of this I also do want to
mention that the pi data conferences
some people are not aware that this we
make money off of these conferences in
order to subsidize all of those services
that we're offering the fiscally
sponsored projects so the money that
you're spending to come to Pi data part
of this is for sure going into things
like our small development grants is
going to support our staff it's going to
support other events it's going to
support legal services for projects so
we have a little bit of a trade-off
going on here where we have income
streams that are coming in so that we
can charge less money to the open source
projects for the product for the
services that we are providing I think
that's a really important trade-off for
people to understand is that you know
when you go to an academic institution
and this is no knock on academic
institutions but if you were to receive
a grant for example you could be paying
upwards of 50 to 60 percent of your
Grant and Grant Administration fees in
order for you to have that for your
project which is the norm at this point
right but if if you have an outside
project and you're working through an
entity-like nub Focus
we would charge 15 percent in order to
administer that Grant because we're able
to subsidize it through other income
streams we're able to do all these
things and we're getting
it's you know the primary function of us
is to be a fiscal entity so we're really
pretty good at handling this I think at
this point
um you know there's always a few
staffies but we we're um the idea of the
amount of money that's flowing through
to the projects and to the organization
is astounding at this point
um you know
starting with just a few projects moving
up to almost was 120 projects at this
point
um it's you know scaled to a degree that
we have millions of dollars flowing
directly to projects as it should
with uh trying to keep our overhead as
low as possible in order to be able to
provide those services
so from here I actually obviously I
mentioned Pi data I'm going to skip all
of this you already saw the Meetup map
but I do want to talk a little bit about
some of the challenges for the future so
um some of the challenges especially for
the non-focus organization that we want
to get into Global diversity is a big
issue this is computers in general by
the way it is very English focused most
programming languages are very English
focused most of the open source
Community is very North America based
um in in general it's hard for us to be
able to represent as a global community
and I think that making sure that we
have better Global diversity is an
important thing that we want to do
um obviously we have foreign events
Jupiter Khan is taking place in in Paris
that one's coming up we have Pi data
Amsterdam Pi data London is coming up
Tel Aviv is coming up as well so we do
have Global events but trying to make
sure that we have some cohesion between
the community worldwide is something
that we're going to get better at and so
the other one is communication
so promoting the projects and Building
Bridges between developers and users
this is something that is an ongoing
conversation there are a lot of
different flavors of Open Source there
are things that are within the mission
of num Focus but there are other I think
that you see the passion for open source
across the entire community and so
making sure that we have those bridges
that we are able to create more
communication is really important I
think and that goes back also to
language barriers and making sure that
we have avenues for people to talk to
each other we do have slack channels we
do have blogs we do have comments coming
in that we do see kind communication
happening on GitHub those are all
important parts of communication
um balancing I mentioned before the the
bomb of data science has changed a lot
of the scientific Community you see this
absolutely everywhere we are a
scientific Computing organization that
is our mission so you know astropi
sunpai worldwide telescope all of these
scientifically oriented projects
sometimes I think get a little bit you
know forgotten in the grander scheme of
of something as big as desk and Jupiter
and IPython and numpy and all of these
other projects that are making a lot of
money out there I mean and so making
sure that we are in the position that we
can provide services for the large
projects and also the smaller projects
in a way that makes sense so that we're
making sure that we're serving both
popular and I don't want to call it both
there's not a divide there but at the
same time making sure that we are being
fair in the way that we are balancing
these things
um open data I think you've probably
noticed that we are very software
oriented as part of those tenants of
open science we want open data so is
there a possibility for us to add data
projects into the nub Focus ecosystem I
think there might be we don't know we'll
see but there are some licensing issues
around that because we're pretty
familiar with software licenses at this
point but data licenses can be a little
bit more tricky especially if people are
you know trying to change data and all
sorts of other things like that so
um but repeatable open science requires
access to data
sustainable funding this comes up all
the time and I mentioned this yesterday
if anyone was at the panel as well that
finding areas of sustainable funding is
a chore every single year it is just
unbelievable I think some people think
of no Focus like oh they fiscally
sponsor all of these things so obviously
they've got a ton of money and they're
just giving all that money to the
projects that's not the case at all
right we help with fundraising we
provide fiscal you know a fiscal entity
but everyone is always raising money for
projects and so sometimes people are
really surprised when they hear about a
really popular project like numpy it's
really relatively large you know
relatively large user Community but the
core development Community is very small
and
I'm I can't speak for all of them but
I'm pretty sure they're not all
millionaires so
um oh gosh sorry this is not good but
anyway but
and also just for us to keep our lights
on I do think that we have very low
overhead as an organization but we do
scramble quite a bit in order to find
sponsors that repeatedly give us money
that we have a constant revenue streams
that are coming in so that we can
provide better service to all of the
projects
um scaling I mentioned before that you
know we're at 120 projects we're going
to keep adding projects we're probably
going to Slough off some that go
inactive but we are you know continue to
grow as you can imagine that when you're
scaling if you have processes that are
you know could be
changing at the same rate as the number
of people who are joining your community
we have higher and higher overhead which
is not something that we really want to
do as leader of a data organization
obviously we need data transformation
we've been talking a lot about this that
we are not a small organization anymore
so I'm just going to go ahead and throw
this out there that if there are any
data scientists who want some practical
experience and want to work with me
personally you're more than welcome to
contact me and we will do a data
transformation on num focus and yeah
like I said practical experience working
with somebody who's very experienced in
the area and um and for sure doing a
really good thing for the community
and security is another one that I
wanted to mention because especially
with some of this legislation that's
coming down out of Europe This is
becoming a bigger issue so
um
hang on one second I just want to make
sure I actually call this the right
thing but it's the uh product the Cyber
resilience Act and the product liability
act in Europe what they're trying to do
is pass legislation in order for uh
there to be responsibility when bugs are
causing issues in software so I think
this is mainly towards data breaches and
huge security holes and things like that
that someone needs to be liable for what
happened by the way this is actually a
legislation that was discussed in the
United States or at least the the core
of it was discussed in the United States
and shot down during the Clinton
Administration so it's not a new idea
but it's definitely gaining traction but
like we saw with gdpr what's passing in
Europe is going to affect us here as
well because we have to be compliant
it's not possible for us to shut off the
hose to all of Europe and so it's not
like we can just suddenly say oh we're
just not going to distribute any open
source into the European area when these
laws were drafted I don't think that
they took open source into consideration
send when they were looking at these
things because for example you know if
we do have what 60 financially you know
tied projects to non-focus that is a lot
of exposure to risk on our part
obviously as the fiscal entity for each
one of those and so
um
if thing there should hopefully there
will be exceptions I think that this is
an ongoing conversation but you know the
psf put a statement out about this
recently but it is something that's
coming up more and more but also there
are task force that are being discussed
about how to address security issues in
open source projects I know it's
something that came up quite a bit when
I was running a team and people would
ask oh is it okay for me to use this
project in my code base because like
isn't there a security risk there so
there's a barrier to adoption there as
well but we do need money to pay
developers to do security fixes this is
a really big deal it's uh you know it
doesn't just happen for free
and so
um that is definitely one of our
challenges for the future
um but I'll go ahead and end there I
have I know I'm a little bit over time
but please a huge thank you to all of
our sponsors to our staff to our board
of directors our advisory Council I do
want to mention by the way our staff
they're they're paid yeah but I mean the
rest of us aren't I don't get paid for
doing this
I'm a volunteer just like everybody else
our board of directors are all
volunteers advisory counselor all
volunteers our committees that are out
there fantastic committees all
volunteers and so we have hundreds of
people who make this community possible
if not more than that even right is but
also just being Advocates donors
Champions
um I think that especially the
passionate users of these projects have
a great influence on how things were
going to move forward and how they can
influence not only adoption of projects
but also the sustainability of the
projects themselves if they can show the
value of using projects it's likely that
we could get more sustainable funding
into the community and so with that I'll
go ahead and stop but thank you so much
for having me and I will be available
for questions afterwards
foreign